let's get back to the phones and by
phones i mean discord
davidpakman.com
discord is the place to go let's go next
to seth from san diego seth welcome
what's on your mind
hey david um i've
i just wanted to ask what
um
you know i see a lot of these
conservative ads
saying let's get wokeness out of our
military and as someone who currently is
serving the country
and this is my own personal opinion i
cannot stress that enough of course is
my own personal opinion
is not affiliating with any of the
branches that i'm serving right now but
when they're saying that
there's like as a person who's in it i'm
like i don't see any wokeness around
here because everyone is so unfiltered
and the only thing you can think of is
sexual harassment seminars or dbaa which
means don't be an you know you know
don't be an a-hole basically
i don't know
anything it's sounding pretty woke to me
no you're of course completely right
you're completely right and honestly i
think the main wokeness allegations came
from when mark milley was saying hey you
know in the military we should know
what's in the culture and so if critical
race theory is something that is being
studied in the culture
we in the military should at least
understand what it is it doesn't mean
anything beyond we should just
understand what it is and that's when
all of the allegations of woke general
and woke military started but as you're
pointing out uh it it doesn't really
have any connection to the reality of
what's going on
exactly because
again like everyone kind of pokes fun at
each other by like well like a lot of
the things they said a lot of race a lot
of racial stuff wasn't out but
definitely some sexual harassment and we
definitely have sexual harassment
seminars yeah going all the way up to
the ranks and we do have extremism in
the ranks which is very popular but
that's not necessarily awoke it's just
more like hey this is professional in
the workplace
we have to be professional in the
workplace but off the clock you can do
whatever you want and that's kind of the
same thing as is the the job i'm
reservist so i work two jobs and there's
a girl that was working and she was
very unprofessional very inappropriate
and i had to say hey what you're saying
is inappropriate you can't be doing that
in the workplace i don't care what you
do outside yeah in the workplace it's
working
and i'm sorry but you have to give up a
little bit of your rights when you work
i mean now you'll agree with that right
i i yes no it's not about giving up
rights it's about
your employer can use any legal means to
determine whether they want you working
there and so like saying we don't allow
black people to work here is not a legal
means saying we believe that's kind
social media statements to be a problem
that actually is legal for employers to
consider if they so choose but that's
sort of a different different discussion
let me ask you this it is um okay do you
find that most of your fellow reservists
are right wing or left wing or sort of
split
i would say
maybe around 60 percent right wing okay
there's definitely hard trumpers in it
and that's not hiding it yeah i would
say around
like the one i know of uh quite a bit of
liberal marines but we kind of kind of
whisper about it we're kind of a little
kind of shut our mouths about it you
know okay it's very it's it seems like
it's very conservative but there are
other people that kind of stay out of it
or they have their own opinions or
they're not that political do you think
that the left wingers at least that you
know in the military
are a little more cautious about
expressing their views because of a
concern as to how it will be received
yes very much so i'm probably one of the
only people
that
can act what is expressing their views
and i have to kind of downplay it a
little bit
but i'm not like scared about it i'm not
afraid of expressing my opinions if
someone asks me politely and i'm fine to
have a discussion yeah uh but yeah
there's a lot of right wingers but i can
at least work with them you know i can
at least tolerate them and we're we'll
die for each other literally that's what
you know that's fine i'm i'm in calm so
it's a little bit of difference yeah but
there's a lot of smart people like i say
all the trump supporters are stupid not
entirely the case their ideas yes but as
a people in general they're just people
they just have the they just have it
switched that's really mean with what it
is
all right seth from san diego powerful
declarations thank you
thank you so much dave i appreciate this
opportunity all right there goes seth
from san diego